uh we've got some very important
announcements we're going to give you
this afternoon
as many nevadans are aware the state
continues to make great strides in this
historic and complex
immunization effort that we are
undertaking we are rapidly
approaching administering our 1
millionth dose of covid19 vaccine
through the state and pharmacy
allocations that have been reported in
nevada web iz
i can't wait to celebrate that historic
landmark hopefully in the next
24 to 48 hours as has been the case
throughout this pandemic
the constantly reported data points and
numbers
don't often times capture the efforts
and impacts
on individuals and families the reality
is
that every vaccine administered every
single one
is one more teacher who feels safe in
the classroom
one more nurse was protected as they
treat patients
one more grandma grandpa will be able to
hug their family members again very soon
and one more front line worker who will
be safe
on the job that's why our vaccination
effort remains the top priority for all
levels of government
throughout nevada and we are seeing the
results every single
day i want to thank the public health
officials
local leaders local health authorities
emergency managers the incredible nevada
national guard
and the fema staff on the ground for
their tremendous efforts
to get shots in the arms and the
progress being made on reaching
particularly
vulnerable nevadans we remain focused on
equity and access throughout this
process
as you know when we first began
administering the covet 19 vaccine at
the very end of 2020
we're getting very small allocations
from the federal government
with only 17 500 doses arriving
in her first allocation for a state with
more than
3.2 million residents
now thanks to more vaccines receiving
approval
and an increase in project production we
received
64 610 first doses to our state
the week beginning march 8th with
automatic second doses based on
vaccine-specific
intervals every time we've seen a
challenge in our state
we've come together to fix it together
facing these challenges can be tough in
a high pressure situation like this one
but no matter what everyone puts their
frustrations aside
and focuses on solutions that's the true
nevada way
i'm so proud of the state's immunization
team led by candace mcdaniel
as we get more doses delivered we're
ready to scale up distribution as well
so that local entities are able to use
the doses
as quickly as possible
because of the increased production and
distribution of vaccine and the
incredible work being done
by the federal state local partners
today i am proud to announce an exciting
update to nevada's vaccination timeline
on march 22nd we will open up
availability
to all nevadans 16 and older with
underlying health conditions
statewide on march 22nd repeating that
will open up availability to all
nevadans 16 and older
with underlying health conditions
vaccination opportunities for this group
of nevadans will be available through
the retail pharmacy program
local health authorities and counties
will continue to vaccinate eligible
nevadans within the front line
essential workforce lane while also
holding events for the general
population
if you are eligible in your county now
we encourage you to make your
appointment as soon as you possibly can
and that's not all president biden
challenged states to ensure
all americans be eligible for covet 19
vaccines no later than may 1st
mr president challenge accepted
beginning on april 5th all nevadans 16
and older will be eligible
to schedule vaccination appointments
statewide
april 5th all nevadans will be eligible
to schedule vaccination appointments i
want to be clear
opening up the state to eligibility on
april 5th
does not mean that every nevadan will be
able to make an appointment
and get a vaccine on april 5th
availability of vaccines
and appointments will still be dependent
on the allocation of doses
we receive from the federal government
however this will allow more nevadans to
schedule appointments
and receive their shot in an easier way
by opening up eligibility to all
nevadans 16 and older on april 5th
means that families friends and
co-workers can seek this
opportunity together which will help
address access
access and hesitancy
the state team is working with our local
partners to ensure we're putting as many
doses
as possible into arms every single day
we know more funding for this type of
work is on the way from the federal
government thanks to the american rescue
plan
and we will continue to scale up these
efforts as funding
comes into our state and while we open
up eligibility
we will also use every resource we have
including
any federal support to scale up efforts
to reach every community
and remove barriers to access for our
most vulnerable
and highest risk of severe illness
people do to kelvin 19.
for many of these populations we know we
need to meet them where they are
at we have started to see this approach
result in success in many of our
communities
and we look forward to expanding these
efforts to every corner
of our state this vaccination campaign
is essential
to getting our country and state back to
normal so that we can all hug our
families
continue getting the veterans back to
work to go to restaurants
send our kids to school play sports
and get together again and as always
mask up practice safe social distancing
and wash your hands frequently the end
is in sight
nevada we can do this we can do this
together
as many nevadans know i got my covet 19
vaccine last week
we got the jansen or the johnson johnson
vaccine as it's called
with front line grocery store workers in
las vegas
it was incredibly important to the state
to of nevada to ensure that frontline
workers
especially those in grocery stores are
those who work in the food service and
hospitality industry
the backbone of our economy we're
prioritized for the covet 19 vaccine
these are folks who cannot work from
home and have been going to work every
day
since this pandemic started serving all
of us
i've said it before and i want to repeat
it here again today
nevada will be the safest place to have
a convention
or come and visit it will be safe for
the tourists
and business travelers it will be safe
for employees
and will be safe for their families we
are
intent on making nevada the safest
healthiest place to come
and vacation or have your next
convention
trichelle the pharmacist who
administered my vaccine was just
incredible i am so thankful for trishell
and so many others across the state who
are helping with vaccine distribution
and administration that includes
pharmacists doctors
nurses volunteers the nevada national
guard
fema and so many more nevadans that have
done their part
for me the immunization process was easy
and painless
and i mean it was painless and i
encourage all nevadans to make their
appointment when they're eligible
whether that is now or in april whenever
you can get an appointment and you're
eligible
please make your appointment and take
the vaccine
in the coming days and weeks we will
have more information available on
exactly where and how to access the
vaccine
when the time comes as always we
encourage nevadans to visit
[Music]
nvcovidfighter.org
for the latest information the vets can
also call the state hotline
at 1-800-401-0946
for more help before i take some cash
questions i want to express my deep
gratitude for the state team
including candice mcdaniel mcdaniel
shannon bennett
and karissa loper for helping create our
covet 19
immunization playbook we wouldn't be
where we're at without their
daily work on this part this playbook
helpless get to this point in our
process
and has been the guidebook throughout
this historic undertaking
we had to make our own playbook because
this has never been done before
on anywhere near this scale up to this
point when vaccines were only available
in limited quantities
we had to follow a science-based
equitable process to prioritize doses
that playbook helped us do that i'm
incredibly grateful for their work every
day
in april with allocations greatly
increased
we're able to set aside the
prioritization portion of the playbook
but many aspects of the playbook would
remain in place
and the hard work from this team and so
many more in the state will continue
through this process including the focus
on equity and access
and as i came in i totally i toured the
health lab with dr pandori this
afternoon
and i want to give a special shout out
to the health lab and dr pandori and his
staff
for the incredible work they have been
doing for over a year now
to get us through this vaccine from the
original making our own test kits to
handling these
tests and the work they continue to do
in determining variance as we move
forward they have been true
leaders in this space and we thank them
for that
thank you for being here today i'll now
be able to take some questions and i
think candace is going to join me if
there's any specific vaccine questions
for her
good afternoon governor good afternoon
i'm checking to see
before the new administration it was
very hard for the state to know
how many vaccines we're getting when
they're coming
all those other types of things with
this new administration and your
confidence
olds and over can start getting
vaccinated in april
do you have a better idea of how many
vaccinations you guys will be getting on
a weekly daily basis
and i mean is that what this projection
is based on
and i think people are curious about the
three vaccinations nobody really gets a
choice
but do you guys determine or who
determines
who gets what vaccine okay uh and yes
thank you for the questions
under this administration president
biden and vice president
harris they have done an incredible job
in increasing our allocation
we have weekly nga calls with the task
force to determine
give us what our allocation was at least
two weeks in advance
they have told us to expect a
significant increase as we move into
april i don't have a specific number but
they have told us that
so we're taking they've been true to
their word every step of the way here
there are three vaccines available and i
want to emphasize to everybody that's
out there
take whatever is available to you i was
with the vice president on
monday the first lady and i were and she
made a comment she says
she took mederina the president took
pfizer and i took johnson and johnson
we've all taken different ones whichever
one is available
at the time for you is the best one to
take they're all high quality
there's been they've eliminated the
hospitalizations and the deaths of
people that are getting vaccinated
so we're very confident moving forward
with anybody thank you
very much did you join edson
so uh thank you daniel anything for the
question um in terms of
which product is at which site we are
very much supporting a lot of
transparency with our partners
so hopefully moving forward we'll be
able in the appointment process to
the actual product will be known thank
you thank you
so other states uh arizona and some
other states around the country most
states actually have taken a more tiered
approach
in their plans for the age eligibility
say you know 55 to 64
or 45 to 54. why is nevada making it
such a kind of jumping full bore into
that
larger age range well we have got as of
today we have initiated vaccines with
better than 25
of our eligible population so we're
making incredible inroads
into the vaccine distribution there's
been some hesitancy and you get people
in an older age group that somebody
younger is taking them and then they're
not eligible to get the vaccine
and what we've done is opened up the
appointments effective april 5th for
everybody
that wants to get it you might have to
wait to get an appointment but
you get on the phone you get a computer
visit the website call the phone number
and
you will be eligible to get a vaccine at
that time
hi governor um this might be for candace
too um
which is fine so i'm wondering does
opening up appointments this broadly
limit your ability to be deliberate or
pinpoint
gaps or shortcomings regarding your
equity goals how do you make sure you're
staying on track with
appointments open this widely
yeah thank you for the question candice
mcdaniel so um we are actually
supporting very
targeted outreach so our health
authorities and our community partners
are working not only to to open up the
access right to
those healthy individuals in april that
there's going to be
and continues to be very targeted
outreach to those communities that are
disproportionately affected
so that entire process will still
continue and
what does it mean to meet them where
they're at in
kind of more tangible terms actual
physical location is just one of those
aspects to where
decreasing that access or that barrier
maybe it might be transportation right
so
that's just one way of actually the
actual location
thank you and
to expand on that just a little bit
we're taking the physical vaccine itself
and the vaccinator into the community to
make it easier so that people everybody
doesn't have a car
and everybody doesn't live on a bus
route so we're taking it in the
community
to make sure everybody has the
opportunity yes ma'am
governor sysolak thank you for your time
my name is madison
my question for you today is we have
some events that northern nevada is
known for coming up in the summer that
have been previously canceled
what does this summer in nevada look
like in your opinion
well i think that our future is looking
good i mean we're making incredible
progress the hope is
uh that we continue to make progress we
get more vaccinations we're going to be
turning this over to the local
jurisdictions
on the first of may and uh that's after
that time we'll have to get approved
still
for seating distancing whatnot we
encourage people to still
remain vigilant wear your mask wash your
hands practice social distancing
but the local authorities will be making
decisions on the different events that
can be held in different communities
hi governor thanks for doing this sure
um i'm curious there are certain
demographics for one reason or another
who may be
suspicious of a vaccine or maybe not
want to get it is there any particular
outreach you're doing to communities who
for whatever reason you know may be a
little wary of this
well and i'll have candice jump into
this too we're going in every community
whether it's some of our minority
communities our black and brown
communities
uh we were a little uh behind i guess in
terms of
the equity distribution it's a priority
for me
for our team it's a priority for the
president vice president that we get in
every single community
and whatever method that is if that's
going into grocery stores in that
community
it's that going into schools or centers
or faith organizations in that community
that's what we're going to do we're
going to take it in the community so
that everybody is protected and has the
opportunity
thank you governor and thank you for the
question um i think that you're just
really having that access
is important but that is informed by
those who those community providers who
know their communities so well
so through the equity collaborative with
immunized nevada they're engaging all
those incredible
partners um to help inform things like
location and so that
process will continue through this
response thank you and just as a
quick follow-up what does that mean for
um i guess people who may be
engaging in online misinformation or
conspiracy theories about this is there
any outreach
as far as those communities
so i do i just promote the
nvcobidfighter.org
website they have incredible information
on their everything from the clinical
trials
to what to expect after you get an
actual vaccination
thank you thank you
good afternoon governor sisolak um so
i'm just wondering about the eviction
moratorium
as of now is there a plan to extend it
past the end of the month
or at least until the backlog of rental
as assistance is cleared
right i appreciate that we're working
and i'm today i want to focus on covet
and
restrictions and vaccines we are working
with our local partners with the
judicial branch
to determine how to handle i've got a
lot of options
on the table right now we're working
night and day to come up with a plan for
that and we should see something in the
future
thank you thank you
and then we'll wrap up not sure if you
saw las vegas mayor currently goodman's
comments today where she
kind of reflecting on the kind of a full
year under the emergency order
said it's basically tent your your
directives have been tantamount to
tyranny
and saying that some of the data the
data she's citing
or the data she's saying doesn't support
the closures that you
kind of push for what's your response to
that
well i've relied since the beginning
since day one
of the covet pandemic on the scientific
data that we had at the time
to make the decisions that i made on
closing businesses closing schools
they have not been easy decisions but
the one thing
that i will stick to and every night
every morning when i get on my knees
when i say my prayers
i pray for the people that we've lost to
covet 19
and i pray for the people that could
still we are going to lose the covet 19.
it's been my priority to protect the
health and well-being of every resident
of the state of nevada
businesses will come back the economy
will come back you're seeing it right
now
it's coming back and it's coming back
strong but in the meantime we've
protected people
as best we possibly can because that's
my priority
and the one thing that won't change is
the economy will come back that store is
going to come back
but that kitchen share when you have
easter dinner
or thanksgiving dinner that's empty
because you lost the love in the clovit
that person's not coming back so that's
been my priority
and that's what i pray about every day
hi governor and again this might be for
candace if so
i apologize um is there a numerical
figure
yeah um is there a numerical thinker or
a rough estimate
of how many more people this makes
eligible
between now and april 5th so can you
subtract out the workforce group
65 and that's a great question and i
you know especially when you look
towards the future right i think what's
difficult at this point
is um the individuals when you just look
at the state of nevada who we have
who have underlying health conditions
that amount of people is duplicative
in the occupational lanes we just don't
have a really great you know
massive database to sort of help us
through those things so
we work really hard to try to try to
project and provide
those those data to our counties but i
think that's something that we're still
still going to work on and look forward
to how do you know you can do this if
it's that difficult to know how many
more people you are being made eligible
so we have watched what's happened
through the occupational groups right so
we measure our allocation and then in
terms of hesitancy
provide the education so it's been our
experience you know since the beginning
since
the the first week in december of the
response that we're getting
i think what's also really promising is
um having more of that johnson product
come
right so the end of march beginning of
april will be a significant increase
you know in the allocation we expect
thanks
so during some of the early rollouts and
even during the kind of
recent weeks people have there's been
complaints about people not being able
to sign up for the vaccine or not being
able to like
easily access the vaccine appointments
given that there's going to be a kind of
a significant surge in the number of
people
who are going to be looking for that
what's the state's plan in terms of
making that
you know making those availabilities or
those appointments
easier to come by or easier to schedule
right and the biggest
obstacle we're still facing is obviously
a shortage of vaccines
right now we have a lot more people want
a vaccine than we have vaccines for
as weeks and months go by we're getting
more and more vaccines and more people
have been vaccinated
so it'll become easier it is difficult
to get an appointment i appreciate that
and we made the playbook we made the
list
with the lanes of people uh we're
getting through as
fast as we possibly can like i said
you're talking the state of nevada
over 25 that means over one in four of
our eligible population has been
vaccinated
as of today that's a lot of people that
we've gotten through
and we're going to continue every day
and people are going to have to get
online make the phone calls and
and show up for your appointments and a
shout out to a county and
local partners that are handling these
appointments that they're doing a great
job in terms of getting we've improved
on the
people not showing up for appointment
situation and no vaccines are going to
waste
uh they've gone above and beyond to get
those needles in people's arms and
continue to do it
are there plans for like more websites
or additional
uh a bill additional ways for people to
access those uh availability
appointments
well i've and if you want to get into
the appointments and
thank you governor um so yes we actually
have this this newer tool
appointment system and i think there's
been
that sort of growing pain working
through it over the last couple of weeks
but as we move into april that will get
under everyone's belt and we'll be able
to use that system statewide
one more there's been
at least now this is unrelated to
the vaccines but there's been
legislation now introduced that would
abolish the death penalty
just curious what your stance is on
abolishing the death penalty in nevada
that's another one that i don't want to
get into i don't know what legislation
is going to come over
to my desk to take a look at but today
we're focusing strictly
on the deadlines of you know next monday
and two weeks from monday on
expanded eligibility vaccines and we'll
get back on all the other questions at a
future conference
thanks anybody else
thank you again that if i could just get
one more chance with your audience
please as soon as you are eligible as
soon as you are eligible
make an appointment get the vaccine
whichever one is available
for you whichever one you can possibly
get get it
you're protecting yourself your family
and our entire state
thank you all god bless you have a nice
night